elle est partie et qu'elle était belle
donc j'ai réussi ça parce que
logiquement cette maladie les gens tu
termines complètement rabougri sur eux
mêmes amaigri
et c'est une horreur en fait et en fait
j'ai réussi à éviter ça parce que parce
que tout simplement c'est certainement
pas
une maladie de creutzfeldt-jakob dans la
forme qu'on la connaît
parce que l aller mieux la semaine
dernière elle commençait à communiquer
avec moi en clignant des yeux
il y avait la kiné kiné tous les jours
et
dimanche en fait on sait pas ce qui
s'est passé
il ya eu
il ya eu une accélération comme il ya
dans
visiblement dans ces maladies qu'on
retrouve dans le kobe donc on retrouve
dans les effets liés au vaccin après
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que finalement j'ai cru que ça allait
être le moment le plus difficile pour
moi
et ça n'a pas été le moment le plus
difficile parce que j'ai l'impression
l'impression que que de toute façon je
ne pouvais pas continuer de la laisser
comme ça et puis
que quoi vous dire en fait
à vers 20 heures hier on savait avec
romain accepté c'était la fin elle
respirait lentement tension était très
basse et vers 20 heures un moment donné
elle a arrêté de respirer complètement
est là
j'ai dit un rom agi mais regarde regarde
le coeur et mon coeur il va encore et
donc après bon je suis pas médecin je me
suis dit bon c'est peut-être normal il
ya une impulsion nerveuses les sens qui
vont est en réalité ça a duré bien dix
minutes un quart d'heure et
c'est complètement ridicule mais par
exemple on a un oxygénateurs bas il y
avait une rallonge dessus j'ai dit à
romain écoute on peut pas aller à
l'essai j'avais peur macaques elle
suffoque
donc je dis c'est pas possible aide moi
on a on a enlevé un des prolongateurs et
gémit l'oxi narrateur le plus près
possible d'elle parce qu'il était à fond
je pouvais plus augmenté on était à 5
rite est en fait la
petite up j'ai fait un truc complètement
ridicule
je les attrape et je vais j'ai fait j'ai
fait du bouche-à-bouche
parce que bon je savais que j'avais pas
la sauver mais je voulais pas qu'elle
souffre est d'un seul coup mais au bout
de ce n'est pas moi vingt minutes après
on a revu sa poitrine commencé à bouger
j'ai dit à romain alors qu'on croyait
qu'elle était morte
jeudi regardons assez incroyable et la
même j'ai dit il faut qu'on en faut en
rire parce que elle est formidable ta
mère elle en train de nous faire encore
un truc et elle s'est mis à respirer
et petit à petit elle a respiré c'était
lent j'ai posé mon lit contre elle je me
suis endormi et à minuit c'est romain
voilà qui m'a secoué on est dans le coup
de papa je crois que c'est fini et en
fait avec le recul je pense que
l a pas voulu en fait elle n'a pas voulu
mourir avant qu'on se couche j'ai
vraiment eu le sentiment est bon
pour vous pour vos mains et marque vous
avez toujours le sentiment que si c'est
le c-max acquis qui nous a pas écoutés
je vais vous dire en fait moi je
voudrais essayer des livres et vous
savez la dernière fois j'avais essayé
toujours faire ça avec beaucoup de
dignité parce que d'abord j'ai
conscience que en dehors du vaccin je
suis pas le seul à avoir au jour pendant
qu'on parle aujourd'hui il ya des gens
qui bavent devant des proches malades et
donc j'ai pas le monopole de la de la
douleur sauf que là effectivement
on a un sentiment d'injustice terrible
et je voudrais essayer quand même qu'on
remette revendre en remettre de l'humain
dans tout ça parce que quand on voit
cette crise du coc vide dont on peut pas
être fier aujourd'hui de dire qu'il ya
des gens quand même et moi je vais vous
dire pourquoi je vous lis à cyril est ce
que l'expérience que j'ai eue là en tant
qu en tant qu'aidant elle est
exceptionnelle vous voyez où je vous
parle ma femme est décédée unis j'ai
décidé de venir ce soir j'espère que ça
choquera personne parce que les gens
vont dire mais c'est quoi il s'affiche
savons que sa femme est morte cette nuit
il est déjà la marque il a fait un long
combat pour mauricette c'est ça ouais
c'est je voulais être là parce que pour
éviter ça à d'autres et en fait ce que
je voudrais vous dire c'est que je pense
qu'on ne peut pas être fier de toute
cette gestion la duke ovide mois pour
moi il n'y a pas de différence entre des
gens qui sont décédés de cette terrible
maladie et des gens qui sont décédés ou
malades ou handicapés du vaccin des
effets secondaires mais on peut pas
ignorer les deux ça existe
malheureusement il ya c'est terrible
mais il ya aussi des gens et je voudrais
qu'on en parle quand même de ça
pourquoi je suis persuadé parce que en
fait
d'être persuadé que c'est le vaccin qui
a tué maurice et mais là j'ai je voulais
jouer vous amener sahraouis de ma femme
d'aujourd'hui me reste plein de
souvenirs et ça c'est formidable il me
reste ça un jour vous aurez tout ça
d'entre les mains qu'un de vos proches
s'appelle un certificat de décès
et voilà ce qu'écrit le médecin qui est
pas quelqu un anti vaccins j'ai
d'ailleurs je supporte plus le terme je
suis pas anti va coin je suis devenu
anti ce vaccin excusez moi
malheureusement je me suis désolé arrêt
cardio respiratoire
maladies neuro dégénératives
très probablement d'origine il y à
trogen voilà ce qui a écrit le médecin
cette nuit parce que si vous savez en
fait on ne décide pas de la maladie de
creutzfeldt jakob
comme morissette est décédé cette nuit
c'est à dire qu'il y avait plus de
sédation
cette maladie est tellement affreuse que
en fait on est obligé de ces dates et
les gens pour éviter des tremblements
vous savez de la vache folle lorsque
l'on a toute cette image en tête on
avait plus de sédation morissette
n'avait plus de sédation donc oui
aujourd'hui je dis que et d'ailleurs il
ya neuf pages d'effets secondaires qui
ont été fournies par pfizer s'est pas
moitié de la vente mais je voudrais vous
alerter par rapport à tout ça parce que
si on continue d'état veulent il va y
avoir d'autres problèmes et on peut pas
continuer de se dire que parce qu'il ya
une épidémie grave d'ailleurs qui a été
classé secret défense moi j'aimerais
qu'on nous explique série pourquoi on
classe une épidémie secret défense
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne considère pas
comme des adultes et qu'on ne doit pas
nous dire bon ben voilà écoutez moi
j'aurais accepté par exemple d'entendre
attention ce virus est très dangereux on
ne connaît pas il peut tuer des millions
de personnes en face de ça on n'a qu'un
vaccin qui est nouveau on n'est pas sûr
qu'il va fonctionner à 100%
mais par contre on sait qu'il peut aussi
par exemple déclencher des maladies vous
avez en vous comme des professeurs me
l'ont dit
si on m'avait dit ça cyril honnêtement
je vous dis vraiment ça avec beaucoup de
sincérité
mais j'y serais pas allé moi parce que
on a tous quelque part potentiellement
ont la possibilité d'avoir une maladie
qu'on peut déclencher
donc dans toute cette affaire je
regrette simplement que on est perdu
beaucoup d'humanité moi j'ai parlé
beaucoup avec des soignants
on peut pas être fier de se dire que
vous avez des gens qui sont décédés du
cobp id tout seul dans une chambre
d'hôpital sans pouvoir serrer la main de
leurs proches à la fin voyez moi
morissette en fait
jusqu'à la fin j'ai pu la rassurer hier
quand je vais je sentais bien que ça
elle partait j'écoute 97 ch j'aimerais
bien que tu reste encore quelques jours
avec moi si tu peux me soit qui décide
voilà
ça me ferait plaisir
vous voyez ça
quand même il faut qu'on sorte de ce
débat pour le vaccin contre le vaccin
mais ça mais juste aujourd'hui vous
parlez souvent de bénéfices et risques
vous en avez marre d'entendre ce ce mot
bénéfice risque c'est vrai que c'est un
beau qu'on a entendues afin une
expression on a beaucoup entendu romain
vous êtes le lot 6 2 de maurice est
pour vous le vaccin vous après votre
maman en huit mois vous savez une fille
de deux ans et demi tu as une fille de
deux ans et demi j'habite en face de la
maison de mes parents à et peut-être 100
m 150 m elle avait l'habitude de venir
trois quatre fois par semaine j'étais
obligé de prendre une nounou après par
la suite elle a été coupé complètement
de sa grand mère
on lui a retiré sa l'on m'a retiré aussi
également ma maman ma conjointe pléa que
je savais que j'aime plus que tout je
fais un coucou à ma fille elle a perdu
sa belle mère aussi il était très proche
montreux suisse et de coups de quoi de
suite suite au bac sont aussi ou plus
dans le jeu je parle de données rement
alors très proche de ma maman elle était
voilà est acceptée dans la famille
ou voilà on nous a enlevé une partie
d'un bien sûr que deux de nos délires
quoi notre idée de notre histoire des
fichiers shsh que d'une chose de toute
façon à partir du moment où dans les
effets secondaires qui sont fournies par
pfizer on vous dit il y a
maladies neuro de nero 10 générer ces
générations et que c'est en fait
irrémédiable je vois je vois pas
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut essayer de
remettre en question je pense que on en
est on en n'est pas là il faut vraiment
quand même essayer de
de chercher de se dire est ce qu'il ya
un médecin
qui vous a dit oui on pense que c'est un
effets secondaires du vaccin jamais
on a deux médecins traitants qui se sont
occupés de marecek ce sont deux femmes
formidables
vous ont dit cn aujourd'hui mois la
semaine dernière quand j'avais j'en ai
une qui est que j'ai eu au téléphone que
je vais expliquer que marc et 7 n'avait
plus du tout de sédation qu'elle allait
mieux qu'elle avait les bras détendu
alors que normalement c'est les bras
comme ça elle m'a dit monsieur de
voiliers au téléphone m'a dit c'est pas
possible c'est pas crossois jack à la
la la le médecin qui a signé ce document
l'après-midi à était venu voir
morissette et moi je cherchais à
comprendre tout le temps mes yeux mais
qu'est ce qui se passe parce que je me
suis un petit peu documenté judith là
normalement ça finit pas comme ça
logiquement vous avez en règle générale
où les gens meurent parce qu'ils sont
trop sédaté ou alors ils font des
complications pulmonaires parce que il
ya des encombrements des glaires et
c'est donc cette technique nous lie à je
rentre un peu dans le détail là c'est
pas ce qui s'est passé non sur le coup
ça s'est mis à flamber à la ceni a
baissé de tension le rythme cardiaque à
baisser sans aucune raison alors que la
veille elle allait bien le médecin tout
de suite m'a dit quand je lui dis mais
écoutez c'est quand même bizarre c'est
ça finit pas comme ça cette maladie
qu'on soit mais elle m'a dit mais
monsieur noyer de toute façon vous le
savez quand votre femme est arrivé au
mois de septembre j'avais des doutes
mais maintenant j'en ai plus c'est le
vaccin
je peux voilà moi je sais pas quoi vous
dire d'autre daniel tous les riders to
froide sur cette affaire non mais c'est
un match est vraiment tellement triste
et puis je vous avais tu es courageux
vous avez vraiment vous vous êtes battus
je crois pour la garder avec vous et
tout ça donc c'est formidable mais c'est
vrai que kaiser m'a tuer ce tweet moi ça
me voilà je trouve ça violent quand même
évidemment qu'il faut il faut enquêter
il faut continuer vous avez besoin de
vérité ça je le comprends tout à fait
mais cette petite phrase la balle mais
j'étais aussi attristé pour vous que
choqué de cette petite phrase là je suis
parce que évidemment il ya un doute
évidemment il faut enquêter on va voir
au fur et à mesure la meilleure aussi
sur la douleur
mauvais rôle de dieu juste que j'ai
ressenti non mais ça n'empêche
évidemment pas ce que je partage
tellement la douleur de sa maman vous
savez maintenant mais je vais vous
répondre à votre combat il va vous
réponds je vais vous répondre vous savez
quand vous avez là il ya quelques jours
face à yzeure qui dit qu' il faut pas
vacciner les femmes qui vont à l'été et
que il ya trois mois ou quatre mois vous
avez le ministre de la santé qui est
tout fier à la télé de vacciner une
femme enceinte comment peut-il savoir
que la femme enceinte qu'il est en train
de vacciner elle ne va pas aller par
était donc vous savez moi c'est plutôt
des choses comme ça qui me choque
effectivement vous savez quand j'écris
finder m'a tuer
vous imaginez même pas comment vous dire
je cherche pas de compassion je mène un
combat aujourd'hui je peux vous dire que
j'ai mené un combat au près de
mauricette jeu les accompagner jusqu'au
bout ce que je peux vous dire maintenant
c'est que mon combat là qui va commencer
il va être terrible pour eux
je vais continuer de le faire avec
beaucoup de dignité mais je vais rien
laisser passer parce que j'ai reçu des
jeux peut dire aujourd'hui des milliers
de témoignages donc moi je veux bien
qu'on continue encore une fois vous
savez moi je suis pour la liberté
j'ai pas l'impression que si je me
vaccine pas demain je vais vous
assassinez vous votre maman parce que
c'est pas moi je suis pas comme ça mais
je veux dire que attendait ne perdons
pas toutes nos valeurs quand même on
peut pas on peut quand même moi si des
gens veulent se faire dit piqûre par
jour mais je respecte leur choix
simplement de ce que je veux c'est que
on respecte aussi le mien et que je suis
propriétaire de mon corps et que si j'ai
décidé de pas me vacciner je me vaccine
pas et pourtant je peux vous assurer que
j'aurai tout l'année mon carnet de
vaccinations j'ai 57 ans j'ai toujours
été vaccinées et quand on y est allé
avec mon ex est on avait confiance mais
sauf qu'encore une fois ci et c'est pour
ça que je vous explique mon m'a tuer
c'est que si on m'avait dit
attention
ce vaccin peut déclencher une maladie
que vous avez en vous je vous donne ma
parole qu'aujourd'hui que je ne serai
pas fait vacciner donc pourquoi ils ne
nous ont pas au minimum quand même
comment on appelle le livre dense et un
peu fatigué le choix libre et éclairé
grâce sûr mais c'est une foutaise
géraldine content quand on nous a rien
dit enfin une question sur cette
histoire comment tu réagis moi j'ai rien
à dire à part vous présenter mes
condoléances les plus sincères je vous
avais dit la dernière fois quand vous
étiez venu que vous avez enfin que vous
dites que vous avez de la chance d'avoir
mme morissette et que maurice est enfin
que vous aviez aussi de la chance et
qu'elle avait de la chance de vous avoir
que je j'ai l'impression que vous l'avez
accompagne et vous monsieur vous n'avez
pas vu la dernière fois donc voilà et
après ben moi j'ai rien à dire je suis
pas médecin j'imagine que votre combat
maintenant commence aussi j'imagine que
vous allez porter plainte ce qu'il faut
que la lumière soit faite absolument
pour tout le monde c'est là un truc
pharmacovigilance c'est sûr alors ça
arrivera évidemment trop tard
malheureusement pour pour mauricette est
pour vous mais voilà moi j'ai confiance
en la médecine ont la science et je me
dis que toute la lumière sera faite sur
cette histoire et nature je pense qu'on
ne nous cache rien en revanche en
battant juan lima que j'ai une question
parce que je ne connais pas la réponse
est ce que vous pensez qu à l époque
quand on a vacciné votre femme on n'a
pas prévenu des possibles effets
secondaires dangereux parce qu'on ne les
connaissait pas ou est ce qu'on vous a
pas prévenu ben parce que c'était mieux
de pas prévenir et de est de vacciner un
petit peu en pagaille à l'effort à faire
il fallait en rafales et parce qu'il
fallait faire vite moi je vais vous dire
mon sentiment parce que je suis pas du
tout complot ti j'essaye toujours de
réfléchir je pense que encore une fois
on efface ils ont le
l'exécutif le présent la fuite
était face à une décision difficile à
prendre parce que certainement qu'on lui
a dit ce que je vous dit tout à l'heure
que c'était un virus qu'on connaissait
pas dans le passé on a des virus qu'on
tué des millions de gens et
qu'effectivement il a fait le choix de
décider de nous vacciner avec des
vaccins qui n'était pas tout à fait
aboutie avec laquelle il y avait des
risques mais je pense qu'effectivement
il était au courant de ça après ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que je crois
qu'effectivement l'a peut-être qu'eux et
ça c'est certain les gens sont pas prêts
à entendre ça peut-être vous peut-être
moi
mais c'est sûr que si d'un seul coup on
avait dit il avait dit à la population
attention ce virus est dangereux
potentiellement il peut il peut faire
mourir 50% de la population française
nolan heureux il ya eu des émeutes dans
la rue de citoyens actionné dans le
monde entier globalement ça n'est pas
que macro et la france oui bien sûr
émission ameddah sont tous les
dirigeants ont certainement eu le même
problème après
j'espère que quand je vais vous dire ça
vous n'allez pas considérer encore une
fois comme étant complotistes parce que
on débat là on entre un des pions
cherche à un instinct cerveau on essaie
de s'en servir je pense quand même que
nous avons affaire malheureusement à des
gens quelque part qui sont des malades
qui joue avec des des virus qui
manipulent des choses et que là
visiblement on est maintenant je crois
qu'il ya des gens raisonnables qui ont
le sentiment que on est face à un truc
qui a été manipulée en laboratoire après
je vais pas vous dire que ça s'est
échappé et que ça a été volontairement
mis dehors qu'on a voulu faire ça parce
qu'on était trop sur le mans dans le
monde parce que ça c'est complètement
débile mais en réalité de toute façon
l'ensemble des victimes ce sont nous
tout cela ici dans ce cas-là tôt sur ce
plateau autour de cette table
après
quoi vous dire
moi on m'a volé va attendre ma ville
alors bien sûr on peut me dire c'est pas
grave en fait bon on va les cinquante
personnes louis morissette ce n'est pas
très grave finalement ces essais que
mauricette
moi mon combat il n'est pas du tout
il va être honnête je suis pas quelqu'un
si demain on guy banon vous êtes trompés
bas je crois connaître et que je me suis
trompé et vous savez géraldine
autour de moi je vous l'avais déjà dit
la dernière fois mais on avait avancé
encore plus c'était un rêve et
neurologue qui a quatre travailler sur
des dossiers et il ya eu une étude
clinique
et il en ressort que les cadeaux entre
guillemets on va dire nouvelle forme de
croissance jacob se sont tous déroulés
comme morissette sauf que elle a joué
les prolongations mais parce qu'elle a
une prise en charge différente avec
toujours les premiers symptômes qui a un
jour après la vaccination
statistiquement c'est impossible où on
est sur une maladie extrêmement rare 1,5
cas sur un million à partir du moment où
vous avez 20 cas où 30 15 avec ce genre
de similitudes il faut se poser les
bonnes questions là actuellement je vais
vous dire j'ai eu le mari là d'une jeune
femme qui à 38 ans qui est en train de
décéder de la même
maladie cpt morissette elle a une petite
fille de trois ans je pense que vous
savez je vous respecte beaucoup parce
que ça l autre fois quand on était venus
je vais demander des nouvelles de votre
maman que ça et moi de l'humain ça me
touche beaucoup j'ai perdu mon papa
j'avais 12 ans il est décédé devant moi
devant mes yeux donc j'ai toujours eu un
problème avec la mort mais j'ai toujours
vécu avec ça mais ça m'a surtout permis
de savoir ce qui était important dans la
vie donc je vais jamais de mauvaise foi
mais là quand moi je me dis il ya une
jeune femme de 38 ans ouvrant des
comptes qu en train de décider d'amal et
du creusot jacob mais à 38 ans on n'a
pas la maladie de crohn jacob elle a une
petite fille de 3 ans qu'est ce qu'on va
lui dire à la petite fille de 3 ans que
finalement c'était pour le bénéfice
risque ce que je voudrais vous êtes vous
demandé aujourd'hui qu'on fasse prendre
conscience aux gens et à ceux qui nous
gouvernent
il faut remettre de l'humain dans tout
ça que ce soit pour le coc i do pour la
vaccination mais on peut pas se
contenter gerling comme vous dites et je
sais que vous êtes très honnête quand
vous dites ça quand vous dites j'ai
confiance en la science sauf que
aujourd'hui
certains acteurs de cette science sont
des malades ils jouent vous savez quand
on parle d'armes bactériologiques
moi j'ai regardé vous pouvez vous
renseigner tout ce que je vous dis
aujourd'hui c'est vérifiable vous avez
l'armée australienne par exemple ça fait
des années qu'ils travaillent sur les
prions parce que le prion c'est une arme
extraordinaire c'est à dire que même si
vous incinérés la personne de toute
façon il ya encore un risque donc vous
savez je pense que c'est plutôt ça vous
pouvez pas simplement vous contentez
géraldine je ne vous adresserai pas vous
en plus vous avez des beaux yeux noirs
comme dans le set
et je suis très sensible à ça elle avait
des yeux noirs magnifique et voyaient
jusqu'à hier soir je levet ses paupières
et je vous regarde et ses beaux yeux
noirs mais vous pouvez pas vous
contenter simplement de dire aujourd'hui
j'ai confiance dans la science c'est
trop simple mais j'ai confiance à la
science parce que j'ai la famille qui a
eu des cancers accueil qui a été soignée
ou ou allongés ou qu'ils avaient de la
douleur et grâce à ça maintenant réparé
mais non mais voilà ce qu'il est
mais bon voilà et moi aussi j'ai convenu
en affichant oui et alors mais pas aux
aveuglement règlement moi non plus alors
qu'on est d'accord à la merci il est
pour ça qu il faut regarder merci marc
boyer merci romain noyez d'avoir été
avec nous ont pas trop penser très fort
à vous vous condamnez nous voir quand
vous voulez
voilà pour à pouvoir comment vous avez
avancé vous savez que c'est toujours
ouvert chez vous ici pour vous et on
pense très fort à mauricette salah et
elle sera toujours là pour vous à vos
côtés toute façon alors si c'est aussi
bizarre
j'ai j'ai beaucoup paniqué avant tout ça
tapait des crises d'angoissé de trois
jours avant avec parce que moi pour moi
de vivre sans elle c'est vrai
mais c'est une belle histoire j'ai
rencontré marcel j'avais 16 ans vous
avez une femme de 32 ans qui a deux
enfants qui tombe amoureux d'un gamin de
16 ans dans un petit village de campagne
plus vieux que ça fait du bruit mais on
ne s'est pas trompé regardez aujourd'hui
moi voilà des 72 ans elle avait une
pêche d'enfer
ce j'étais amoureux d'elle encore comme
au premier jour c'est fusionnel
j'ai eu peur de ça mais là c'est bizarre
parce que depuis maintenant quelques
heures là je lui parle et j'ai
l'impression que finalement qu'elle soit
qu'elle se soit éteinte à la maison son
esprit rester là avec moi peut-être que
je m'accroche à ça c'est peut-être
ridicule mais on a tous besoin de
s'accrocher parfois des choses tiens
donc voilà je suis vous remercie cyril
parce que je sais que vous avez aussi de
vraies qualités humaines ainsi main
simplement ce que je voudrais voilà des
durées ce soir c'est que s'il vous plaît
tous ensemble on peut pas voir ce qu'on
voit là en chine où on menotte les gens
pour aller chercher et les vaccinés de
force c'est pas possible on va pas
devenir ça même si on a confiance dans
l'affirmation